hello and welcome back to the shaky
sideshow so I'd also hear something
different again in this video and tell
you ten biology jokes that I quite like
so what are the best ways to break the
ice of people is to make a joke and I
feel like not quite enough people do it
these days besides like the horrific
jokes that's you hear on Christmas Day
although actually quite like some of
those so I've scoured the internet and
my own brain and my own inventiveness to
come up with a list of the top 10
biology related jokes basically it's me
telling jokes for five minutes
what more could you really want so Duke
at number 10 so today my biology lesson
we were detecting an AI and so I kept
trying to think of puns but to be honest
they just kept getting cornea and cornea
number 9
what did Gregor Mendel say when he
founded genetics okay I'm having too
much fun with us joke number eight did
you hear about the famous microbiologist
who traveled in 30 different countries
and learned to speak 6 languages well he
was a man of many cultures Jake number
seven so we just hired a new molecular
biologist Wow isn't he small Jake number
six so there were two plants and one
plant said to the other young gray and
the other replied I could use a light
snack Jake number five so Paige had
spent hours well many many many hours
pricing hi biology dissertation and
famous today where she could finally
hand it in to the lecturer so the lights
were you know you just quickly flicked
through her dissertation but realized
something was missing and the lecture
went where's your appendix page easy
page said and she points to my lower
abdomen so now was answered Jake number
four hello class today we'll be learning
about the liver and the pancreas
up in the gallery of the lecture room
medical students leading to the other
end said damn isn't one thing I can't
stand is an organ recital down to Jake
number three so there was a red blood
cell and the red blood cells and sided
they wanted to go to a very busy
restaurant so from personal experience
if you ever go to a restaurant when it's
very busy you're often asked if you want
to set up at the bar so as expected then
the hostess asked which I'd assess at
the bar the red buds are kind of being
shrunk that are from abides they thanks
I'd rather circulates oh down to joke
number two for my PhD projects I decided
to grow a human Faygo cords from stem
cells in the lab well the results speak
for themselves
okay so we're finally down to joke
number one but before I do the big
reveal I just want to say if you
disagree with my choices all have even
better jokes to share I would love to
hear them add into my repertoire and so
on to the this final Jake which I'm
thinking a little bit biased because
this is my own personal Jake
personalized and tassels and sudden I
made of myself anyway the final Jake
so the preschool said next just then at
top speed for ten minutes
well I passed out after two well that's
it for my top ten biology themed jokes I
hope you enjoyed them and yeah you have
any others I'd love to have them I just
really like telling jokes thanks for
listening